you have such a legacy of a career would
you mind talking to me really quickly
about a few of them and playing my
favorite game
if something comes to your mind fly on
the wall moment something nobody knows
I'm gonna go straight to Gremlins
first time I saw the puppets not
realizing they were puppets okay so if
the little Mogwai right Gizmo yeah Gizmo
so he's up on the counter and he's
moving around and he's doing all the
stuff and I was like it's it's real it's
live they've got a real thing I don't
know what the thing is but it's a thing
and it lives so I thought it was real
until I then looked underneath the
floorboard and there was like 11 guys
laying underneath and they're all
working these different Hydraulics and
stuff and moving the eyes and moving the
eyelashes and moving everything and they
got me because there is that one scene
in the movie where I'm going like this I
go raise your arms and he raises his
arms blink your eyes that was all real I
was like maybe if I catch him off guard
he'll show me he's really alive so
that's what I was doing and Joe caught
that magical moment and that actually
ended up in the film I love it I love it
I love it I love I love Joe Dante the
amazing director okay Goonies
so many great things you know I still
I'm still close with every one of them
Sean and I are still like brothers key
and I are still Brothers Jeff and I
still talk all the time like we are all
still a family really it's amazing it's
amazing I mean 30 whatever years later
and we still write each other Merry
Christmas on a thread email I'm not
joking like the way Steven was for you
the way he was like a father figure to
you when you needed him and he was like
there for you same thing with dick
Donner for me like he was literally like
my everything because I didn't have a
dad I didn't have anybody you know to
really lean on and he was he was the guy
that paid for my rehab he was the guy
that was there for me when I needed help
he was the one that you know would go in
and and say Corey Feldman is is a
stand-up guy don't believe these
ridiculous rumors are spreading you know
and he would he was always there for me
my number one memory of Goonies is the
family that we created and the love we
created and it still resonates today oh
that electric in that chemistry it's
real because we all feed off of it it's
as current as any movie and it is a gold
standard I have never not heard as of so
recently everybody trying to say well
it's going to be like Goonies I mean it
really is right and not only that but
there's a sequel apparently that's been
on IMDb for the last 20 years but it's
never gone into production would you
ever do it if it did listen back when
dick was alive we were all pining for it
in fact Sean and I actually wrote a
treatment at one point really and we
presented it to dick and Steven's
assistant and Chris and they loved it
but they said it was too expensive at
the time which I didn't understand I'm
like if you're gonna do a sequel to this
movie it's got to be expensive and the
words of pretty women
um woman big mistake huge right right
the Lost eyes
well Corey I mean Corey that's
ah
yeah
I mean how can I think of Lost Boys and
not think of Corey first but
um Bittersweet Bittersweet we met on
that film really that's where you that's
where it all happened uh in fact it was
before we started production it's in the
wardrobe room I'm sitting there doing my
fitting Joel Schumacher's on the phone
and he says oh my God I'm so excited
about this we have the best cast ever we
have the two quarries social and I go
two quarries what do you mean two
there's only one I'm right here you know
and he's like no no no two quarries and
then I found out because I get a call on
my answering machine from Corey who says
hey man what's up dude it's Corey Haim
uh so we're going to be working together
bro it's going to be awesome so I
figured maybe you know since we're in
the same town we're working on a movie
together maybe we should like get
together and like go to the beach or
something give me a call bro Letang we
got together we went to the beach our
dads met we threw a football around and
the rest is history
I can't even talk about this movie
without getting emotional because
um
I was the host of Turner Classic Movies
the essentials for three years and I
picked this movie to talk about we did
30 movies a year and I think it's one of
the finest films ever made in the
history of Cinema Stand By Me
[Applause]
Rob Reiner it's all about Rob Reiner of
course of course Stand by Me was a very
important period for all of us because
it really was the coming of age that you
see on the screen so much so that the
first thought and I know this is
terrible but the first no I like where
this is going the first thought that
came to mind was me and River Phoenix
renting dirty movies
[Laughter]
watching them and giggling together but
the reason why uh it came into my mind
is because I was at a Roger Waters
concert about six months ago and Reynold
Gideon the writer of Stand By Me the
screenplay writer he goes you know I
want to tell you a funny story I said
what's that he goes well I don't know if
you remember this but you know you were
young right you were 12 or whatever and
you weren't able to go rent movies on
your own so I figured I would help you
out by using my card to get you you know
whatever you needed from the video
stores you had some entertainment so I
put my card down and we did that and you
know I got the bill at the end of it and
I expected to see like Disney Princess
movies or something or you know maybe
Superman or something like that but
instead I find Caligula
all right man whoops uh we were doing
research research for our characters
trying to figure out how to come of age
and now we know better it's true when we
talk about Corey Haim and River Phoenix
and
you know so many of our peers it is
amazing that we are thriving I don't
know why the success rate is so hard I
don't know why having access to
everything I mean think about you had to
go and like seek this out now we have
the internet and the flick of a finger
everything is accessed and now we're
both parents and it trips me out to
think that we probably never would have
wished on kids to have that much access
and now we're in it with every parent on
the planet trying to protect our kids
and keep them kids and innocence
have the pitfalls that you and I were
exposed to my child has just turned 18.
oh my God so I can now proudly say I
made it through 18 years without an
arrest without that call from the
principal so I am eternally grateful
that we managed to make it through 18
years without any problems
and that that's the gift right like like
we know we had messed up childhoods
right we know that we wanted to do what
we could
I think even more so by overcompensating
to make sure that we did a really good
job with our kids right nothing has ever
been more important to me right than
being the parent that I expect of myself
it makes me the most proud there's
nothing I will ever do in this world and
in this life that's more important to me
than raising good girls that's right
[Applause]
thank you
congratulations
ladies and gentlemen my dear old friend
Corey Feldman thank you so much
[Music]